all right we are now live for another
reading from my book
[Music]
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
and we have been going through the
translations of the
various authors involved in this we've
looked at
blondel angel sean brady
guy marcel um to many of these are
pretty familiar names i would say
um today we're going to read and it's a
short section
uh of the book the
sixth uh
translation it's a short selection by a
guy named etienne bourne um kind of a
minor character and before we jump into
it i'll say why did i include this one
in the work
well i think that it
presents another
interesting
position on the
entire issue of christian philosophy
that as as i read through it you'll
you'll see what he's saying i think he
advanced the debate in a way that many
of the other
50 or so interlocutors only some of them
did
and this is going to be very short this
is about uh seven
six pages actually
because it begins at halfway down the
page and ends halfway down the page
so um
no further ado let me start reading
from eighteen borns on a christian
philosophy that would be philosophical
printed in the journal esprit november
1932 edition
the problem is not only that of knowing
whether christian philosophy is a
historical reality illustrated by names
of notable wait a saint augustine
or a saint thomas a mall brash or maine
de berra or whether christianity is or
is not a climate favorable to
metaphysical research and discovery
the philosopher's attitude towards these
secondary problems will depend
on what he makes of a fundamental
problem one that must be raised with the
most brutal
simplicity is the idea of christian
philosophy a contradictory notion one
that claims to wed fire and water
critical and autonomous reason with
blind and submissive faith or is there
to the contrary a natural friendship
between the intellect that knows and the
intellect that believes and the response
that the philosopher will provide for
this problem the very way in which he
defines and opposes its terms will
depend right at the start on the idea of
philosophy he makes for himself of what
i will by convention and to be brief
call his reflexive philosophy
actually if this or that historian
condemns the idea of christian
philosophy it is a priori and because
for him whoever says philosophy means
reasons autonomy and intellectual
evidence supremacy over all obscure and
irrational modes of knowing over faith
prejudice or feeling from this point of
view granting that christianity can be
matter for reflection by a liberated
thought that will be able to discern in
its myths the foreshadowing or the
symbol of rational truths
it will not be able to contribute to
reason a rule
and a measure it will be fatal to the
mind's freedom
what reflexive philosophy does such an
attitude imply
some criticize medieval philosophy for
example with not having having given
humanity any new truths with having been
merely and apologetic applied to proving
semblances of proof to prop up an
unverifiable revelation
but this supposes that philosophy's
progress is analogous to tracing a line
that follows itself out innately owing
nothing to anything other than itself
never returning to itself and
ceaselessly adding something new to the
old
material fortunes grow themselves this
way
but matters do not work this way for
spiritual goods
even positive science and i'm thinking
especially about modern physics which is
not hesitate to call its very own
principles into question
is far
from corresponding to this simplistic
schema progress is in metaphysical
wisdom could in fact not lie in ever
renewed com contribution of previously
unknown truths in labor that would add
discoveries to discoveries onto infinity
for if the mind is not a pure freedom
a power of fabricating novelty
philosophical progress must be
envisioned in a less simplistic and
material way
philosophy is not as contemporary
idealism imagines the only means for
establishing and growing the treasury of
truths that are humanity's common
patrimony we have heard the kojito
celebrated so much that we naively
believe that only philosophers think
but how many truths are acquired and
lived in the morally good person's
practice the artist's intuition the
believer's faith
no philosophy discovered the conscience
and certainty of duty
even before there were philosophers
human beings knew the emotion that
beauty awakens or the feeling of
respectful fear before god which is the
beginning of all religion
does this mean that these spontaneous
and immediate experiences of truth would
render philosophy useless no
since the proper function of metaphysics
is rediscovering by rational means an
objective communicable expression of
these confused and irresistibly realist
data that the intuitions of the good the
beautiful and the divine are
philosophical thinking's very exercise
presupposes prior to itself the
existence and the value of certainties
acquired and tested by other means of
which some perhaps the most important
ones will remain by nature beyond
philosophy's competence
it will not add to this set of
certainties some certainties radically
new with respect to their object it will
not discover i know what intelligible
new worlds
the world that the philosopher knows is
the same as that within which
man is born
suffers and dies but he knows it in his
own way
a speculative disinterested and rational
way
he will invent a previously unknown way
of being certain about things certain
elsewhere
this is another light on the same object
which does not illuminate the whole of
the object which but which perfectly
illuminates the part it shines on
a new degree of knowing is added a new
order of knowledge is discovered that of
universal necessity an order of
certainty new in relation to the world
which gives us new assurances about the
object already discovered and explored
this certainty whose life is rational
justification
for there can be different modes of
knowing the same object it is the same
god
that the believer the theologian the
philosophers speak about
but each in their own language
and each in an order of absolutely
original knowing irreducible to any
other
if this analysis is correct the idea of
philosophical progress takes a different
shape the acquisitions of the meta
physical intellect are not always
provisional and endlessly surpass
results and they come back either to an
always more penetrating deepening of
immutable truths presented to every
human consciousness or to a reflection
on the discoveries already made by the
intuition of the morally good person or
of the artist and by the believer's
faith and to reason's effort to clarify
them philosophy thereby possesses the
fullness of its own autonomy the free
use of its method but it must admit to
itself
this is the part of reflexive philosophy
which is another
other consciousness that philosophy must
develop itself
that is destiny not to contribute
absolutely novel objects of knowledge to
humanity
for prior to itself it presupposes a
human experience one that discovers and
lives the truth's philosophy will in its
own way justify by illuminating them
with reason
the idea of a christian philosophy takes
on a signification and value from this
point on nobody can be surprised that
christianity has contributed to the
world a body of truths of which certain
ones were from their own nature on
reason's level and which philosophy then
acquired as if they were its very own
goods
a reflection on a datum acquired by
intuition or all the more received by
grace
and in which metaphysical analysis will
discover an intelligible aspect without
striving for its profound mystery
greek philosophy never suspected that
god is love a confidence made to saint
john that exceeds and humiliates reason
and one that the human heart would not
dare to foresee
and then notice how philosophy sets
itself to reflect on this deposit
humanity is received from christianity
certainly it will not transform mystery
into light removed from faith it's
obscurity and from the believer his or
her merit it will take this belief as a
certainty of fact and it will ask itself
what god's nature must be
so that it would be possible to affirm
that he is love
it will tell itself that love being a
total gift of self must fountain forth
from a center of freedom and initiative
in a word if god is love he is a person
so informed reason now goes into
dialogue with itself
and perceives that following just the
demands of rational necessity
it is obliged to attribute this
perfection personality to god
you know uh it has therefore enriched
the idea of god it is made for itself
thanks to revelations aid
by right it would have been able to
raise itself by its own powers to the
notion of a personal god but factually
it needed that its attention be
attracted by faith to the divine charity
so that it would become conscious that
it already implicitly knew that god is a
person
here a serious objection is raised you
have treated only someone will say to us
the exterior of the problem to be sure
you have shown philosophy's dependency
with respect to human experience and
consequently on what is most conquering
and dynamic in that experience that is
christianity the true problem of
christian philosophy is something
completely different a philosophy is
christian only if it has made us a human
nature open to the supernatural and if
it is thereby justified the demand for
grace by uncovering the grasping point
that man offers to god's hand
if it is capable of integrating
everything human into man's yes to his
supernatural vocation
a key problem impossible to elude and
one that imposes itself universally but
that our imagination too quickly fixes
to a particular solution that can be
provided to it
so that a philosophy can call itself
christian they repeat to us it needs to
be a restlessness not a science to the
degree that it advances and it discovers
more contradictions and antinomies and
knowledge in an action it convinces
itself of its own powerlessness to lift
them and to form conclusions once and
for all
in this way man's powerlessness to
fulfill his vocation without the
gratuitousness of aid coming from
somewhere else will be displayed and
also his powerlessness to go to the very
limits of a reason that demands unity
and encounters only oppositions and
divisions if it does not accept the
obscurity of faith in this way
philosophy's insufficiency will be the
fundamental truth of christian
philosophy
quite a contestable position
let philosophy be a dialectic of
deception and it is no longer philosophy
let it be able to raise a single problem
without being capable of contributing
the solution to it and i become
suspicious of philosophy just as with a
friend who does not keep his or her
promises christian philosophy cannot
establish itself at philosophy's expense
but if philosophy is docile to the truth
the problem we raise right now will find
itself resolved quickly enough at least
in principle
i have tried to make us see the
following
philosophy suffices on to itself and it
establishes an order that has its
internal and original justification but
this order must be
situated in a hierarchy by nature it has
its place within human experience if
philosophy suffices on to itself because
it must justify from its own resources
alone all that it advances it is quite
clear it does not suffice onto man this
is the fundamental truth of reflexive
philosophy
from this fact other modes of knowledge
of being whether it is a matter of
exploring it or suffering it are
possible
outside of philosophy every ah priori
rejection of the supernatural can
therefore be dogmatically rejected
furthermore
philosophy analyzing the mind structure
in its own way that is speculatively and
disinterestedly necessarily and without
recognizing them as such discovers the
conditions of the possibility of
supernatural elevation
the mind in fact is not a power of
construction but rather intellectually
an attention and morally a striving even
in its own most rational life thus we
find philosophy working on its own
denies the extrinsicism of the
supernatural and without this being
proposed to it explicitly
finally
reflects of philosophy
comparing the scientific
moral
aesthetic religious universes
perceives analogies and correspondences
between them
each of these universes has its own
existence and its own proper principles
philosophy which has not created them
leaves to each of them its autonomy but
it has a duty to itself of discovering
at these different stages of spiritual
life the mind submission and of
abandoning itself to an object that is
its master and its guide truth goodness
beauty or the divine infinite
to each of these orders man appears the
same a power of acceptance a deep
docility thus everything human in the
act of faith
can be integrated more and more closely
in order to be christian therefore
philosophy does not have to renounce
itself and place itself in foreign hands
in its very nature it will find the
implicit desire unknown to itself for
living in a christian state
for philosophy knows and it is its task
to say so that the human intellect is
not a creative divinity finding all of
its subsistence in itself and capable of
dispensing with all experience
the self-proclaimed philosophy of
idealism wishes to misunderstand this
dependency of philosophy in relation to
the rest of human culture a dependency
that is nevertheless inscribed in its
very nature
and in this sense
philosophy is like an open and docile
person
and grace can make it advance along the
steps of philosophy just as it makes
human freedom advance along the steps of
freedom
that's the end of this very short piece
by atien bourne which i think is really
a
great contribution to the debates
stressing some
key ideas that are all too easily
left out or misunderstood especially by
philosophers who tend to
ascribe to their discipline
you know something that other
and i'll say existentialists because
born is a christian existentialist uh
along with people like you know
kierkegaard and miguel de una muno and
gabriel marcel and arguably even maurice
blondel
something that all too easily gets left
out the
philosophizing that takes place
does not take place by robots or in a
vacuum or by the
imaginary people that philosophers like
to put forward it happens with real
people
who are informed individually and
culturally and socially
by
many other things beyond and besides
philosophy
what born is calling reflexive
philosophy
um i think
a lot of other people would i mean
that's a french term that that we see
being used by um people like you know um
maurice blondell jacques palliard all
these other people
um good question by mc1 what 20th
century french philosopher is an
existentialist and the answer would be
most of them
i mean french philosophy uh is all over
the place right so he mentioned
idealists ideas would include leon
branchfig would include all sorts of
other people as well at the time
um the rationalists were not really
existentialists so
when you have a superficial
understanding of french philosophy that
comes largely
from seeing a few big names it's easy to
say yeah a lot of them were
existentialists after all we have sartre
bubar camus
gabriel marcel blondell did not call
himself an existentialist he called what
he was doing the method of imminence
bergson is not an existentialist he's
doing something a bit different
but if we go beyond 19 you know 50
existentialism was viewed as kind of old
hat post structuralism is not
existentialism right and so all of these
people
like duluz and leotard and
um
derrida and foucault
they are not only not existentialists
they're also reacting against
existentialism
we find that french feminist philosophy
other than simone de beauvoir
very often turns against existentialism
as well look at christeva irigarei and
suzu and people like that
there's also a very strong french
marxist tradition you know people know
although because he's a famous figure
for having killed his wife but more
important than him i would say is ahri
lafave right
and very often the the marxists were
anti-existentialist because they thought
that existentialism
was far too individualistic um and we
could go on and on and on before the
post-structuralists we obviously have
the structuralist claude levy strauss
and roland bartz who's kind of a bridge
figure
um and then we have the psychoanalytic
uh people like jacques lacaze so
existentialism is just one out of many
different
branches within
20th century french philosophy
any other questions about the
[Music]
topics born brought up the book itself
the debates
um we have a good bit of time for
q a
it's not a general ama we'll be doing
that this weekend i should mention too
in case anybody while anybody's writing
stuff down so we are not going to be
having
a lot of these readings this month
in part because
next week
my wife has like you know we work in the
same space and she is running women's
entrepreneurship week so i won't be
doing anything that um uh interferes
with with that in terms of like the
sound space where she's recording stuff
um
i might actually be able to do it on the
18th i had a doctor's appointment that's
being moved so i'll probably uh
move one there i'm not going to do one
on thanksgiving american thanksgiving
the 25th and we only have
four thursdays within uh this month so
so yeah we'll do another one the next
one coming up is gonna
lead us into maurice blondel's third
contribution to the debate uh the
problem of catholic philosophy which was
a seminar sort of thing
published in lazitude philosophy so
we'll read through his presentation
it's about eight pages and then we'll
look at the letters received
with responses by maurice blondell
we'll look at the letters by
castelli devil v
goulier and mara shall and then there's
a dialogue between blondel jacques
paliar and gaston beershare and that
will take us to the end of part two of
the book
and then there's
five other pieces to go through with
that
all right uh dr beavis just wanted to
say i appreciate your contributions to
the philosophical internet sphere i
haven't watched many vids recently but
soon we'll binge them soon i'm sure well
you got plenty to choose from i've i've
crossed the 2000 video
boundary uh without realizing it
sometime back
there's there's a lot of stuff there but
you know i've been
doing that for uh
more than 10 years now so
and i keep grinding away it'll be
interesting to see what happens with
this medium
as time goes on
we don't know whether this is going to
be
something stable something that lasts or
you know like i mean
this this is lasting books are lasting
uh even though we've got ebooks and
things like that
um but i don't know we'll see what
happens with youtube videos
and where they go after that
should be kind of kind of interesting so
yeah any other uh questions
about the
book
topics
bourne's contribution ideas things like
that
otherwise we'll
call it a a day and end this one a
little bit early because you know
obviously it's a short piece
um
so mc1 you're going to have to be a
little bit more clear about what you're
asking considering christian philosophy
anselm or aquinas they're both christian
philosophers
um they're both important within the
canon i'm not sure what you're
you're asking about
so if you can uh explain a little bit
more when you with what that or is
supposed to signify
i will point out that anselm is one of
the important sources for thomas aquinas
all you have to do is look at all of his
discussions about truth or original sin
or stuff like that you'll see that he
actually
takes anselm as somebody who basically
has things right
and um
works off of of anselm's stuff
he by the way aquinas rejects anselm's
proselogian but not monologian argument
for the existence of god which is itself
a cosmological argument um in uh soma
contra gentiles and somatiologia and
then later on in the commentary on the
psalms says
oh by the way anselm is right
deus est or deus essa is in fact piersei
nota but it's not pierce nota to
everybody it's just parasai nota to the
sapientes the wise
not exactly what anselm is saying but
um
[Music]
you know close enough for for something
kind of interesting
uh dr bevis any secular historical books
about christianity you'd recommend not
really i mean there's millions if not
millions there's thousands of books out
there right
um and uh i i don't you know i don't
spend a lot of time digging around with
secondary literature i mean one one one
book that i've gone back to over and
over again is you know meeks the origins
of christian morality but that's about
like you know philosophy and culture and
the in the late roman empire and how
christianity is forming but
um that's just on like one particular
topic
so
ricky i wonder what christian
philosophical views are on the gospel of
thomas there are none i mean
uh not from the debates because they
didn't have the gospel of thomas that's
coming from naga mahdi right and that's
a later thing and
you know
when when you say christian
philosophical you have to ask what i
what idea of christian philosophy a
person has because one thing that's
super super clear from the debates is
there is no one single
conception of christian philosophy there
are a entire constellation some of which
are probably
better thought out and more adequate
some of which are you know
clearly inadequate to to it
but
you're not gonna you know you're not
finding the people in the debates
focusing heavily on gospels or on canon
or stuff like that
uh
mathias what do you think about carl
bart's use of kierkegaard his approach
to natural theology i mean i'm not a bar
i'm not a big bart guy so
he's not involved in the debates at all
he's kind of off in the distance doing
his own thing even even the francophone
christian philosophy debates in the
1940s and 50s with you know like rosie
meow
and
i'm blanking on his name
paul recur plays a role in that they
don't they don't pay that much attention
to bart quite frankly
um bart bart is somebody i think who
really caught on in certain circles
of theology
but when you look at his impact on other
circles even in reformed theology he's
not is not really that that big
um
so
he's kind of an outlier in many respects
i mean bart would essentially be
somebody you know who i think would
exemplify what jill song calls
theologism
um takes a phedia's point of view a lot
of the time
i don't know enough about what bart has
to say about kierkegaard to really do
much
say much intelligible about that
um
[Music]
but yeah so
that's kind of a blast from the past i
mean
i haven't you know i guess the circles i
move in i haven't heard too many people
talking about bart recently um
but he was he was talked about quite a
bit uh as sort of like the you know the
bad guy
when i was in college of course the
people that i was taking classes from
were very liberal theologians so you
know
um
that was that was that
so
all right uh
the area is there any discussion of the
antichrist and anti-christian philosophy
in these debates what do you think about
the idea of the antichrist i think i
mean antichrist is is a silly notion in
the hands of most people today there's
an an antichrist there's being
antichrist being anti-christian
and i would say i mean i'm going to go
out and say something that'll probably
be controversial i would say here in
america at least half of the people who
call themselves christians are actually
antichrist
if you look at what's actually preached
in the gospels and how they behave
and they will if there is anything like
the reckoning that's that's presented in
the gospels they will find themselves
being the people that christ says
sorry [ __ ] i don't know you you know
they were not interested in in that i
mean that was not that was not a real
significant topic for most people in
christianity throughout the ages all
these sort of apocalyptic worries about
the antichrist that's mostly outlier
stuff
historically
there are certain times where that
becomes a big deal but
you know i think a lot of people
who see contemporary christianity
wind up um getting to see
uh
you know weird wacky crap supplant the
the gospels you know
dr bevis they became the oppressors they
were fighting pretty quick we live in
the shadow of christian oppression
and i mean
history is a lot more complicated than
that i mean if if that if that makes you
feel good to say that sort of thing to
think that sort of thing then more power
to you but that that ain't the history
it's way more complicated than that
dan is it generally accepted that that
the is or is not christian philosophy
today in philosophy i'm not sure what
that means are you saying
is christian philosophy accepted within
philosophy
uh there's no general answer to that it
depends on where you are who you're
studying with there is no like consensus
in philosophy about what philosophy is
we live in an incredibly
pluralistic time and um you know anybody
who tries to like i mean i did a whole
video on this anybody who tries to
define philosophy is just this
generally they wind up um
leaving out most of what we call
philosophy
and so
i mean it kind of depends on how you
teach it right
is descartes christian philosophy
descartes tells us that he is
so if you're teaching descartes how do
you teach descartes do you teach him and
like strip all the god stuff away or do
you say
you know this this these are important
considerations for him like pascal
points out he does need god to get his
project going but it's not the same
thing as the god of abraham isaac and
jake jacob
these are you know these are all things
that you'd want to point out and again
you notice i keep bringing up the same
thing
the field of philosophy is complicated
is incredibly complicated there
generally aren't any sweeping assertions
that are going to be correct
again mc1 asks the same question as
christian philosophy accepted in modern
day philosophy whose philosophy
you gotta ask that question so unless
you can localize it
um
you know
there's there's not much you can do
muhammad i have difficulty understanding
christian philosophy because it's not no
way convincing god is three and one at
the same time it's just one example
i mean if if christian philosophy
depends on you understanding the trinity
then yeah it's gonna be a non-starter
for you if you think that's all
christian philosophy is
maybe do some more reading
you know uh read some boethius
you won't run into the trinity and
consolation of philosophy
um he does have uh you know thing on the
the um
trinity which you can read that might be
helpful for you
do you need to understand the trinity to
be able to read
augustine
probably not augustine thought the
trinity was kind of complicated so
that's to me that's kind of a cop-out
and you know christian philosophy is not
all about the trinity i mean a great
place to start would be getting yourself
the spirit of medieval philosophy uh
jill stone's uh gifford lectures and
looking at all the different topics that
he's he is discussing dr beavis no
sweeping statements indeed hard to talk
about such topics without encapsulating
the nuance of our complicated world yeah
i mean
uh
you you can
you can make sweeping statements the
trouble is is that
by their very nature they're probably
going to be off base and then they're
going to drag you along
sort of like with almost a magnetic
attraction in their wake
and you know it's not to say that there
isn't any truth to them whatsoever but
they often conceal much more than they
they reveal so
you know
um
worth worth checking out
so
all right well any other any other
questions about the debates the topics
those sorts of things
so
not next week but two weeks from today
we'll go back into the book and get back
to one of the key figures maurice
blondel it's always nice to go to bourne
he's the guy i wish i knew more about
you know
um but i don't know that much about
someday i always had like the intention
of like writing a history of the debates
never got around to it as all of you
know i'm kind of a busy guy so
mark just came here that's that's nice
yeah well mark you know you you did miss
everything today but
you know it's recorded so you can you
can check it out so all right that's a
good place to to end this
um hope all of you have a great weekend
and we'll do this again two weeks from
now with a much longer entry
um somebody who's much more central to
the debates than born was so i will see
you later